sur cette affaire de Zara vous avez vu
ou pas cette publicitaire Zara alors
j'ai j'ai pas compris en fait le bail
j'ai vu ça sur les réseaux c'était
avantti parce que c'est vrai que j'étais
pas mal sur les réseaux ce weekend et
non non c'est vrai et j'ai vu ça
certains internautes appellent à
boycotter la marque accusé de se moquer
des victimes palestiniennes à Gaza en
cause une série de photos publiées sur
leur compte insta qu'on va vous montrer
dans un instant regardez et dites-nous
ce que vous en pensez est-ce que vous
êtes choqué par la campagne publicitaire
de Zara ou ou pas dites-nous et on en
parle juste après ça a été c'est encore
en top tweet he je sa plus il y a eu
plus de 340000 tweets ça a été un truc
de fou dans le monde entier en plus
c'est était un truc de fou regardez non
mais ce weekend l'enseigne de prête
àortter Zara a lancé une campagne de pub
pour promouvoir sa nouvelle collection
mais avec ses mannequins enveloppés et
ses photos prises dans un décor
déstructuré certains considèrent qu'il
s'agit d'une référence à la guerre entre
Israël et le Hamas et accuse Zara de se
moquer des morts à Gaza si certaines
photos ont été supprimées par l'ensene
de nombreux internautes ont
immédiatement appelé à boycotter la
marque
espagnole alors sac mortuaire appelle au
boycotte êtes-vous choqué par la
campagne publicitaire de
Zara
alors G est choqué c'est honteux c'est
scandaleux vous vous rendez compte il y
a des images de manquin avec des
linceuls on a l'impression d'être dans
des funérailles de musulmanans il y a le
décor en carton pâte une carte de la
Palestine il se moque des Mor de Gaza je
n'ai jamais vu ça souvent on dénonce des
campagnes de publicité mais celle-là
elle fait mal elle est terrible je
comprends l'appel au boycotte Cyril
c'est un scandale qu'on a sous nos yeux
non mais Gilles tu plaisantes ah non je
plaisante pas du tout je je ne sais pas
pourquoi par quel fantasme vous avez
déliré en voyant ça s'appelle comment la
campagne atelier d'artiste moi ce que je
vois là c'est si vous avez été dans un
musée déjà vous avez vu des caisses vous
avez vu des statues qui sont enveloppées
dans des dans des Dra blancs comme ça et
et à aucun moment il y a une carte de la
Palestine si si découp pas en carton
bien sûr que c'est fait exprès vous
Valérie ben vous êtes
tombé la carteavis pas vu cro oui avais
pas la carte JEI pas y croire mais quand
je la
voisaccord on on va revenir sur vous
après Géral maill non en fait moi mon
truc c'est que une fois que j'ai vu la
polémique avec des explications très
très très très très longues sur le poste
en fait je n'arrivais pas à comprendre
où était le problème en fait il faut
qu'on me l'explique avec une légende
très longement donc fait pas croire que
la marque Zara et fait une sorte de
brainstorming il y a un mois et demi 2
mois avec Tim Walker qui est le
photographe de cette campagne que je
connais avec qui j'ai bossé qui est très
connu qui a fait cette photo en 2016
donc qui est très connu avec la même
égérie Christian mcnamani qui s'amuse
voilà donc là on peut dire aussi que
c'est quand même aussi une sorte de
scène un Fournier un truc très très
choquant ça il a fait cette photo en
2016 donc ça veut dire qu'il y a 2 mois
ils ont fait une réunion à New York avec
Tim Walker et Zara et toute la prod en
disant alors qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire de bien pourri de bien immonde de
bien obsè pour avoir un truc tendancieux
sur la guerre mais enfin je ils sont je
veux bien que le business soit cynique
et complètement dingue mais je pense que
c'est je pense que vous faites fausse
route j'ai l'impression que j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde est à
côté de la plaque non vraiment j'ai
côté de la plaque moi l'interprétation
que j'en fais alors peut-être que je
suis le seul mais c'est plutôt l'inverse
de tout ce que vous dites c'est-àdire
que j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt
une dénonciation de ce qui se passe en
Palestine je vous rappelle que il y a
quelques mois enfin il y a un mois
précisément ils ont posté une photo Zara
avec une femme avec une écharpe verte un
fau rouge enfin bref le drapeau
potentiellement de la la Palestine donc
ils en sont pas leur coup d'essès et ça
serait totalement cohérent que
aujourd'hui ils partagent ce ce cette
photo qui soit là peut-être avec un
message pour dénoncer en effet tous ces
morts en Palestine pourquoi tout de
suite prendre l'interprétation et le
pied de c'est pour se moquer pourquoi se
moquer Gill je comprends pas pour cette
photo là juste celle là juste celle
toute seule c'est la situation à Gaza ou
c'est la campagne la par cette photo seu
v n Se moqu c'est du c'est chercher du
bad buz du double bad buz pour faire ser
une dénonciation pourquoi ça sera pas
une dénonciation ils on fait exè
j'aimerais euh la tour du P et m dire
j'aurais pas le droit à un argument
laissz vos camppr car s'il vous plaît
Kell également Hugo également merci non
mais moi les les campagnes de de de pub
quand on parle de vêtement qui enfin
voilà qui qui peuvent susciter ce genre
de débat ça me dérange pour ça c'est
pour ça que je mis oui à partir du
moment où on en parle et la photo par ça
peut être instrumentalisé aussi oui mais
regarde mais oui mais quand tu fais une
campagne de pub que tues photographes tu
cherches pas ça cherch ça la ligne rouge
moi c'est ça qui me dérange tu vois mais
très honnêtement quand tu fais cette
quand tu fais une photo dans que tu
intitules atelier d'artiste dans un
concept qui est un atelier d'artiste tu
peux imaginer qu'à un moment on va se
dire que il y a un
par ça depuis 2016 regarde ça aussi
enfin voilà à partir du moment où tu as
fait cette première photo et tu fais ça
derrière c'està franchement c'est plutôt
une campagne un peu ratée quand on
connaî les campagnes justement de de
Zara quand on voit celle-ci alors je
dirais pas peut-être qui qu'ils l'ont
fait exprès je pense que c'est raté euh
ceux qui ont eu la Réunion et qui ont et
qui ont dit bon on va on va partir
là-dessus je pense que aujourd'hui il y
a le pays un peu sensible c'est très
sensible euh moi pour moi elle porte un
cadavre voilà elle porte un cadavre et
et et je ne vois que ça donc je trouve
que c'est une une une campagne ultra
ratée maintenant bravo à eux parce
qu'ils ont fait le buzz et malgré qu'il
y en a qui boycottent bah ils vont quand
même Mo parce que moi j'ai commencé à
regarder ce que disaient les gens sur
les sur X et cetera et sur tous les
réseaux sociaux et alors tu as une
bataille des uns et des autres et et
chacun envie de de de de poser son sa
grille de lecture sur le truc alors tu
as des gens qui disent et tu as
évidemment des gens aussi très mal
intentionnés qui imagine qu'il y a une
sorte de complot sioniste parce que il y
aurait des dirigeants juifs à la tête de
Zara qui voudrai influer et se moquer de
il y a un moment où on part dans des
délires faut mettre ce que c'est pour il
faut dire ce que c'est pour ce que c'est
c'est-à-dire une campagne de pub qui
peut-être est foiré mais parce que je
trouve que c'est de toute façon un très
mauvais timing quoi qu'il en soit c'est
le timing qui qui est zéro l' luême
pourquoi pas mais pas en ce moment je
crois qu'on est en plein drame et que
tout se passe très mal dans le monde et
qu'on est ass divisé comme ça de faire
un truc pareil quiacur je suis désolé
moi je n'adère pasandiv TOSC Sho pendant
Béon je sais pas un homme qui est en
train de
mourir là des DRAM épouvant ctésj des
problèmes avec les Ouigours il a déjà
des problèmes avec cette marque là ils
ontjà été en top depuis des années B je
pense qu'il devrai plutôt fermer leur
bouche et ne pas simisser dans les dans
les problèmes Mondia ça les concerne pas
Kelly regarde tout le monde transpose la
photo qu'on a vu de la jeune fille vrai
regarde la photo qu'on a vu de la jeune
fille euh en en vert avec et on a dit
c'est une photo propalestinienne cette
fois-ci on dit c'est une photo entre
guillemets pro sioniste antipalestinien
donc tu vois bien qu' il y a une grille
de et pourtant ce sont deux photos Zara
donc tu vois bien que chacun projette
des fantasmes en fait vous voyez pas le
décor de Gaza en ruine derrière la photo
derrière tu vois le Tr palestinen plus
le cor d'un musulman qu'on transp dans
un vous voz pas
ça pourquoi il aurent soutenu à ce
momentl la Palestine en mettant le
drapeau palestinien et après le parfait
opposé schop
pasére
regarde tu VO
bien
s'ppelle il le stratéie donc vraiment il
y a 2 mois ou il y a un mois ils ont
fait une réunion pour dire on va essayer
de faire ça pour essayer de choquer tout
le monde parce c'est bien d'avoir un bad
buz aujourd'hui à ce pointl alors que la
situation elle est électrique et
catastropique ils ont peut-être fait la
Réunion il y a de TR mois mais c'était
peut-être aussi le moment de dire non on
la sort pas moi c'est pas le truc de
politique je vois pas de politique moi
quand je une nana avec une écharpe verte
derrière une porte rouge je vois pas de
drapeau moi je me dis juste ça c'est une
campagne raté comme a dit mundir qu'elle
a un cadavre sur l'épaule et comme a dit
Bernard c'est dit ça divise c'est pas le
moment de voir ça on a pas envie de voir
ça c'est que ça moi je trouve ça de
mauvais goût un cadavre dans un sa
toujours fait ça depuis années
annouver anné de mettre des cavr surépau
d'un femme je
trve plus pens téléspectateurs il shoot
mais c'est pas c'est pas réussi regarde
il se fout dans la merde non à 68 % oui
à 31 % voilà donc sont pas choqué à 68 à
68 % et donc à 31 % ils sont choqués